biochemical networks
thank you
thank you for the invitation to this
great workshop
so
so i'm following the advice i'm going to
a whiteboard talk which i have never
given i gave many blackboard talks at
all times but never whiteboard
that advice
so
my talk is
more a little bit of information and a
little bit of philosophy to invite you
it's more like an invitation for you to
be interested in these questions
so i will just
at some moment so the the i will give an
introduction with some definitions and
some positions
and then
some
recent work by
other people and my some work in
progress by my myself and then i will
end with some questions but it's mostly
very you know
i don't know how to qualify you will
qualify after i am
so we start with the introduction
and as i said this is mostly an
invitation for you
so what i would like to speak about
is that uh it's about some
polynomial system that arise in fact
there are polynomial dynamical systems
that autonomous polynomial dynamical
systems that arise in the study of
biochemical reaction networks they also
rise in
chemical networks they also rise in
population dynamics etc but i really
want to concentrate on the feature of
these biochemical networks which are
more specific not just so general
but for me what's spectacular is that
what we can say is really close to what
people in applications are interested in
so we are really close to say things
that matter to people who work in
biology biochemistry or whatever
so i will start by uh an example
so this is an example of bacterial
signaling system
it's what's called two component
osmoregulation in e coli
and it's very interesting it's a
mechanism that nature has that one would
like to abstract but there's no
abstraction yet
so and i will use the the notation that
it's in general used by uh chemists or
biochemists so at the beginning i was a
little bit puzzled but why don't you
call the variables x1 up to xn is
because if you give a name you know
what's the function of this
species chemical species so you can
predict what's going to happen because
different variables correspond to
different chemical species that will
behave differently so this drives your
mind okay so it is like this system one
is there is
this x is called um
sensor kinase this is a kind of protein
a protein is a chain of amino acids
and amino acids are undefined
so you will see as i go on
that my knowledge of biochemistry is not
deep i hope knowledge of math is deeper
than this but
i will tell you what i understood
and so this
i will tell you all this is called xp
this means that i have this x this is a
kindness that can be transformed into
this other form
and then it can
sell phosphorylate this adds a
phosphoform to x i will explain more
this what this means
and then when it is in
x form that then it can uh
so in xp form it somehow can interchange
the phosphate with y
so there is here an intermediate
complex
in fact this is just one but this is the
name of one variable okay
and then this goes to x loses the
phosphate and y acquires the phosphate
this is equation one
equation two
well this is not a question this is a
bunch of reactions here there are three
reactions here there are as many
reactions as arrows you have a directed
graph
and here are the what's called the
chemical complexes which are made of
species here the species are xpy etc
and this is one species which is at the
same time one complex
and then the third one is in form xp it
transfers the phosphate and when it is
in form xt it takes it away
again this is long name is the name for
intermediate complex
and then what you get is xt
plus y
so
this is what is called a bifunctional
enzyme so if x is in this state it
produces it gives the phosphate and if
it is in this state it takes it away
sorry where does the phosphate go at the
end
it takes so it's been taken away
it's been taken away it's not model
so
in general okay let me let me explain
you what i understand of it so the
enzyme is a big molecule
enzyme is there
and then for instance when the
phosphorylation takes place then the one
uh the substrate binds to one part and
the force when it is there it may be i
know it's shifted or not in such a way
that can get the phosphate the phosphate
we are not
modeling either there's enough phosphate
in the ambience so that some way can
take it
and maybe there's another molecule this
that which is there and when the
the the substrate gets there the faucet
can get away we are not modeling the
phosphates
justice is the name
of this substrate but it really means
that it has a phosphate
okay so and
this has
this is this is the direct label
directed like directed graph there are
other labels that i'm not writing here
but which are
the reaction rates of each reaction in
fact what i'm going to do is i'm going
to number
the
nodes 1 2 3
four five six
seven eight nine
so i'm going to give the to the right
constant which are positive real numbers
for instead of go from four to five i
will call this k k45 etcetera okay
so
and
in this case there are
seven species this is the number of
variables
there are
sorry nine
nodes which are nine complexes which are
made of these seven variables
and there are nine reactions this is the
number of arrows number of vertices and
this is the number of variables that are
involved okay
and i will write here a similar system
system two
so instead of one we have one prime
which
x
not only can be transformed and
transformed into x t
but it can only be transformed into x d
this is an atp or adp
group that gets added so it has can be
so
two and three are the same
but there is a fourth reaction that says
in xd form it can also dephosphorylate
so x t plus y it takes the phosphate
away
okay let me write down for you which are
the equations here okay the question for
one
so here the variables so i'm going to to
name the variables from x1 up to x7
and then in fact we can
write the same system you know
maybe it could be nicer for us
so we can i will write it this way our
goal x will be going to be x1
and xt is 2 and xp3
and this is x3 times x6
you will see why this you this was seen
also in an stock
this is because of mass action
that i'm going to label with monomials
these monomials correspond to the fact
that the probabilities are independent
probabilities are here the constant so
in fact our what our variables mean is x
i is the concentration
of the eye
species and what we think and this is
going to vary over time and so i'm going
to this is the the network and this
network imposes some dynamics that under
mass action kinetics
which i like to tell the story that is a
very mathematical
framework and it was proposed
i have to hurry it was proposed by a
chemist and a mathematician altogether
it was a very chemical was a
mathematician involved and the chemist
was the
great grandfather of ragnay bin who
those who know her okay the questions
are like this
so it's x one dot
let me write down this one a k one two x
one plus k two one x two
plus k plus x f
seven
and then
x two
so
so for instance here and then we go on
so here why so we have
one in fact two three four five six
this is because x2 which is xt
appearing
here there so i look at all the arrows
that have somewhere and xt and i have to
put everything there okay
and then the the in general what we have
is that this y i is the label for the
eighth note
and then you have a reaction
with constant k i j which is assumed to
be a positive real number that goes to y
then the system of equation is of this
shape
x dot means the vector of derivatives
this is length s
is is equal to f of x this is these are
f1 f2 fs
they happen to be polynomials
and then for each reaction that we have
in our graph
we have the rate constant
the source complex
by i and then here
this is an integer vector which is the
different of the exponents in this
polynomial so these are in fact the
exponents of the monomials
and so this is an integer vector of
length s so these are if you look at
each of the coordinates this is some
integer times a real number transient
monomial so we get polynomials
but there is a combinatorial structure
here that comes from the reaction
because these correspond to the
reactions okay so in general what will
happen
that in the season that we consider
all the monomials are are going to be of
this shape either
a single
variable or a product of two variables
so this is why our exponents our y's are
going to be 0 1 vector so the
differences are going to have entries 0
1 and -1 that's why we don't see any
other integer here
okay
so
the and also in this case it's not
difficult so in general if you have
x dot equals f of x
so meaning that x i equals f i of x
then it is obvious but let me write it
down if i find
any linear combination of the with real
coefficients of the s
then this means that
the sum of the derivatives of the x
chi's is going to be zero
so this is going to be a constant
along trajectories so this gives each
linear combination among the f's gives
the conservation what's called the
conservation relation okay
and there is a natural space
so what i wanted to say here is that
in this this this is called a two
component system when the
phosphate gets transferred from x to y
but here x t is what's called an enzyme
so at the beginning at the end we have
this
is there to just to produce to catalyze
the reaction but it ends being
unmodified okay and in general when you
have a enzymatic network this is the
standard way of writing is this is
called an intermediate complex
and this is the michaelis-menten
formalist for or standard modeling for a
enzymatic network but there are many
others
and in fact one of the things i would
like to point out if i have time and see
that no it's not so obvious that they
will have time
is that
people really don't know what's
happening here there could be many what
they say is that they are too quick they
cannot measure them and they really know
don't know whether it's one or a hundred
or how they there could be a cloud of
intermediates they don't know
so one question that we can answer is
well what's the difference is if instead
of one we have several
and then they interact what what's the
what's the difference in the output
okay so something also i'm going to be
very quick now because i was i won't say
anything
is that each of those so
imposes a linear constraint
but something else so which are the f's
so we get something of this form the
question is which which are the f's this
this answer is well known
but which are the f
i
that show up
this way
for mass section
and the answer was given by two uh
guys from hungary hearts that i think it
has an accent somewhere on top
this is an article
we call it the hungarian lima and we
knew of it by
george creation
and it's it says okay it comes if and
only if
each f i
can be written this way p i minus x i q
i
where both p i and q are have
non-negative coefficients this means
that in the i polynomial if you see a
negative coefficient then the monomial
has to be divisible by x i this is very
easy to see and what this imposes
is something natural in the
in the constraint of the dynamics if you
are supposed to model concentrations of
chemical species is that the
non-negative organ is a forwarding value
for the trajectories if you start with a
non-zero solution then you can positive
solution you can go up to the boundary
but it cannot become negative which is
natural
but
what happens
is that if i but if i get any gi any
and then i take x i gi already has this
form i mean all the polynomials are
polynomials with real coefficients okay
if i start with anyone
i'll just multiply by x i and then it
will has the shape because all monomials
are divisible by x i
of course if i change this will do is
the dynamics is going to change
so for instance which
polynomials but if i look if i try to
look for the positive solutions for this
steady states
then if i want to look for the positive
is in general looking for just a generic
any polynomial system so there should be
essentially no constraint
and if we
there are
things that can be said so this comes
from this combinatorial information i'm
running out of time
and i haven't even set it
so we have this so it's very easy to see
that okay this is a mild restriction but
in general it imposes some interesting
positive conditions
that lie behind
and also in general if i have the system
constantly not be identifiable and if i
have the system the graph is
there are infinitely many graphs that
give the same system
but if we do have a graph to start with
we can use this information and it's
very rich combinatorial information so
and in nature there are some these
modelings are not just any graph that
are some particular kinds of graph
that essentially are
generalizations of what i'm writing here
so what's particular about these two
systems
is that so i haven't written all the
equations but there's like this it's not
it's not obvious but what's happening
is that if we solve these equations it
happens that if we pick a solution with
non-zero coordinates the value of x7 is
constant
so the zeros outside the coordinate x's
have a fixed value of x7 so this is in
fact in this case there are two
in this case there are two conservation
relations
two conservation relations means that
out of these seven polynomials only five
are linearly independent
so they cut out a positive dimensional
variety
so in general have a positive
dimensional variety we expect that the
zeros will depend on all the variables
in fact here
y p
is constant
for positive solutions
independently of the rate constants so
if the rate costs are changed they will
be get another value but independent of
the conservation laws independent of
everything
so the question is
this is the basic one of the questions
is
why is nature
regulating this because this is a
mechanism that nature found to regulate
this behavior to have an yp
is just essentially constant
so how which are the other mechanisms
that can produce this okay here this
exploration is this by functionality of
the enzyme
okay so in general what we have as
unexplained is we have this
we have this for instance let me just
make one drawing
so we have this subspace
which is the the space of linear
relations
and then we have the parallel translates
where the dynamics takes place so the
dynamics takes place here so we start in
the positive order we are going to move
here
and for instance the zeros of our f
could be something like this
so this means that here there is only
one so what what is really interesting
so if we start here we can only move
here okay so it's a natural question if
you have just one positive steady state
where the the solutions are going to
converge here even if it is
locally stable asymptotically stable
because solutions can go to the boundary
and there are many many many interesting
questions so in this setting or the
unsolved question says there are many
cases there is just one
solution why is it stable so in general
if there is one it is stable and what i
learned this is obvious but i learned
this recently
what
biochemists and biologists observe are
only stable statistics the steady state
is not stable you don't observe it but
they observe it so it is stable
but
so it's a very general so we have very
general polynomial system one so not
just the question of global convergence
just local conversion why a general one
is stable so this means that the
negative uh the the eigenvalues of the
jacobian have negatively alpha it's not
obvious it seems symmetric to have
positive and negative but all these
systems have many features i don't know
why and there are many questions
regarding this this system
okay in the maybe three minutes that i
have
uh
let me tell you what what's what happens
here okay so there are many questions
but i don't so i
this is not something about i wanted to
tell you much more so this is not about
uh
complexity but i do believe in
complexity
so what we want to if you if we want to
compute we have to be clever otherwise
we cannot compute so which are the main
questions so the main question is
explain the loss of nature okay we can
it's too big
second question is give us some maybe as
i answered give
a explain the geography of parameters
phase we have this all these parameters
here the parameters leave in r to the
nine and here is how many
arrows
so we have this big open first quarter
in r to the nine and it it is possible
to prove
it's easy that there is a semi algebraic
decomposition of this orphan
such in this
in each of these subsets they have there
is the same qualitative behavior
find this decomposition this is not
doable only for toy examples
so but the idea is if we can understand
which are the main structures main
components which are there so we have to
throw away everything which is not
essential which is irrelevant and then
study some small models so their story
of studying small mothers goes back
maybe to uri alone he
devised a word called the
motives motives and there's just because
we can only study small pieces and try
to extrapolate this is also maybe
something that anna was telling she has
this nice paper with badalioshi
from lassie in the journal of
mathematical chemistry on how to
extrapolate from sub-networks
if you wish on the other side this in
the algebra geometric setting what this
means is that we want to understand when
we get a fiber of a map this fiber
it's it's the limit of the nearby fibers
so somehow this is the question
and there is a very very nice paper by
alicenda philium and carson buff that
was published last year
in a journal of
the royal society interface was called
simplifying biochemical networks where
they explained that what's what's the
role of these intermediates and
when are they important when what's
happening
and so with my former students
mercedes-benz emilia and what we are
doing is we are devising a sign of
if you want some axioms that define what
we call
multi maybe the name at the time we
publish whether the name will be better
this is multi-component
e s
i networks this is enzyme substrate
intermediates
and but we allow what are called the
cascades so we don't so something one
species can act in some part as an
uh as a substrate
and then in some other pipe could be the
enzyme for some other reaction so there
are many many examples that we have seen
in the literature that enter
this framework that i
not defining for you
but what i and what we did is we we
devised when we can
read
from the combinatorics of the network
that we're going to get what we call
tourist steady space the idea generated
by the f is going to be a binomial idea
because then many things can be answered
easily but if there are many questions
for instance for this system which are
for instance this kind of systems it
happens that when we want to answer
about
positive real solutions it is enough to
answer non-zero complex solutions and
the algebra gives you positive by three
something there are some hidden
conditions
that allow for in general in this system
this happens this you you don't need to
to separate comp if you look non-zero
complex in general you get positive
so what i think is there many many
questions from the
uh
yeah so what i mean is mean is that for
instance what we really want so the
steady steady states are the real zeros
of the polynomials which vanish on the
positive roots of the f's
they don't lie to be they they're
more like the real radical the positive
real radical this is what one needs to
compute polynomials one is interesting
understanding the polynomials advantage
on the positive solutions of our idea
which in gel is is not it's radical but
it happens to be the same as the
saturation of the ideal in all these
examples
but for a reason that i don't know why
okay i don't know which is the reason
but there are many
algebraic questions and there are many
questions related to the dynamics and
all the answers are really close to what
they want from us so
this is the end story for the time
it's a remarkable equilibrium in the
middle there you said okay after you
talk about biologists all observe things
they're actually stable equally rooms
they say something about we've only seen
things
mathematically that are stapled no no no
what do you observe in the lab
yes yes
so this means that when we are modeling
all these things
that correspond to experiments that they
do
and we find one solution we know also so
answering his question so
we did the following so they have also
what they call
everything that they observe is stable
for us proving that this table is a mess
because we have the parameters a kx the
parameters x sorry the parameters k
and it's a question of real quantifier
elimination with incredibly many
variables it's
it's you can pause it it's a seminar
question but it's some you cannot do it
but they
they see them they change it but they
see them so you know that if you can
prove that there is one solution you
know that is stable because they observe
it
okay
so we can prove a fear i'm saying there
is one solution then we for some reason
is stable and something just less common
about the the
dynamic so when the system is
conservative
some conservative means that when when
the the steady state when this when you
intersect this linear space with the
ortho and you get some which is compact
then what happens is that the
trajectories you start with something
which is never said or you start with t
equals t equals zero and you go on if it
is compact then certainly the solutions
are defined up to plus infinity you can
go all the way
and something that is not said but it's
also provable now i know how to prove it
is that if you have a trajectory that
converges it converts to a state so the
steady states are the limits of
trajectories and trajectories
of course trajectories do not need to
have a limit
okay
but in many of it it has not been proven
that in these cases the only thing that
you could have are just
trajectories conversion to a steady
state but it happens but i don't know
the reason so and there is no
for the moment i haven't seen anything
real serious about algebraic treatment
of stable oscillations i don't know how
to deal with this but and this could
occur for us a lot couple tera equations
which are this rabbit and
uh so these um these are have a stable
limit cycle and they are of this form of
mass action kinetic but they are very
different they are not they don't have
this shape and just let me tell you the
last comment you are not asking for it
but there for me
so uh last year i
was at the lecture given by gene farrell
he's a biochemist in stanford
he made many important papers he's a
very nice person and his major was in
math and physics so you realize when he
speaks that he likes math which in
general
people from biology are kind of afraid i
i'm getting recorded i don't i didn't
say that
but it happens so it's so he has a taste
for it
but he was explained he also does
experiments so he they have some all
sides of some frogs
and somehow he showed some pictures and
there were two stable steady states one
was an immature i don't sorry for my
pronunciation it was not completely
mature or side and the other was mature
outside but this is a stable steady
state but stability means that after
this unless something terrible as an
earthquake i don't know what or the
change in temperature or something this
is going to be a frog
so things that we see as irreversibility
in time is just because it's a stable
steady state when you have a stable
steady state it will go on the reactions
will go on
just as you are here you are not going
to move and you see we see so there are
these are very important things i mean
it's not just for me
for me the more most interesting thing
is that it's just these are not just
mathematical definitions but there are
things that really related to what for
me so my background is very from
theoretical mathematics so i'm very
happy to feel this so sorry okay thanks